[Music]
been a long time coming
it happened we've been sitting here with
these masks i'm over the mask two years
two years when we started this g3 stuff
this gorilla collective gc stuff i i
mean
we had to rock these yeah but i think
it's about time it's about time to take
them off let's take these off and let's
get right into it people what is
happening everyone welcome to gc3 the
gorilla collective 3 summer showcase the
least pretentious showcase you will see
this summer that hat trick the 3p the
menage anyway
i am your host justin woodward
co-founder of the mix the media indie
exchange and terabyte entertainment and
advisor of the black game developer fund
as well as black voice to gaming i'm
with my amazing co-host the green eyed
bandit can't stand it candace mckinney
how's it going candy it's going great
justin i am so happy to be here
co-hosting gc3 and kicking off the
summer with everybody
really kick it off tough the gorilla
collective was created because
everything was fragmented in terms of
the press and event organization during
the zombie apocalypse of 2020 so we
decided to come together organize and
deploy showcases with our fellow
independent hustlers in the game
industry and add some flavor and style
to the industry to give folks a creative
jolt during the chaos that was ensuing
the gorilla collector's main message is
unity we are carrying on the tradition
of organization with these showcases
with leading game studios publishers and
industry leaders independently to share
announcements gameplay reveals updates
and drops from studios of all sizes
direct to everyone watching worldwide so
this week we started black voices and
gaming and today we will blow things up
with gc3 showcasing a wide range of
games and then we'll hand it off to our
friends over at wholesome games for
their wholesome direct showcase later on
this week we'll have the gc 3.5 where
we're going to share some fresh games
that are crispy and lit they're going to
be mad crispy but not burnt before we
get started we have to give a huge shout
out to our sponsors playstation razer
astro gaming tencent our fellow devs and
publishers 11-bit acappara all in games
assemble entertainment aurora punks
freedom graffiti gravity games arise
hero craft modern wolf raw fury tiny
build wire productions also salute to
the developers who played a role in the
showcase they have contributed their
games and resources to make this
possible
and once again you guys we've teamed up
with the fine folks at valve to showcase
our stream on their platform in order to
support the devs be sure to check out
the gorilla collective three event page
on steam where you can learn more about
the games buy games that are available
now or add them to your wish list for
the games that haven't been released yet
these wishlists really help the devs so
let's do it definitely check out the
wishlist support the devs they will love
it shout out to our broadcasting
partners for supporting the showcase and
the developers on the stream twitch
steam ign of course gamespot we are
trying something out new this time
around uh we're gonna be doing key drops
through qr codes randomly during the
showcase so please have your phones
ready to grab some codes from the
gorilla collective gc3 also let's say
hello to our mix master gorilla squad
partners who are co-streaming today you
all are amazing be sure to check out all
of the great reactions and commentary
from them
let's get started with the first set of
games that go od
this summer beginning with a hardcore
soul seeker simulation a soul like
action rpg as well as some up-and-coming
games and a few exclusive surprises on
the horizon for release
let's get started i can't wait
all squads report in kilos ready for
takeoff
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
what's up
oh yeah
[Music]
whoo
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
candy how alot has come such a long way
and is looking really impressive i
remember when that game just got started
looking forward to checking that out as
well as boundaries shooting folks in
space what coming up next we're going
gonna get serious with some games that
may scare you a little and then
transition to some more narrative driven
situations that might make you
contemplate life we got a full roller
coaster of emotions coming up let's go
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
of any drugs or if it was actually a
witchcraft ritual as indicated by the
evidence found at the scene
suggesting the latter police officers
found books at the scene containing
strange symbols candles
the first victim was her own 75 year old
father
madison mutilated his body in such a way
that his face was unrecognizable
his body
hours later madison continues
[Music]
[Music]
this is impossible
this place didn't look like this a
second ago
chains
maybe i can break them with something
[Music]
[Music]
what the hell am i doing
[Music]
the doorbell
i i gotta get to the front door
so
[Music]
[Music]
rated teen
walter
[Music]
oh my god what
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god is this right
[Music]
for
each other
one day
[Music]
hey guys it's carl from 11b studios i'm
glad to be back at guerrilla collective
because we've been pretty busy for the
last two years so first of all i would
like to introduce luquitaker from state
of play the creators of southwest circle
because they would like to tell you more
about how they are creating games
i'm luke whittaker i'm creative director
of state of play we made south of the
circle which is a narrative adventure
game set in antarctica in the 1960s
[Music]
we've decided on such an unusual setting
because i was fascinated by the surreal
beauty of antarctica
our lead character peter's experience in
antarctica remembering all these past
got me thinking about
my own
experiences my own memories and how
my memories of past events are often
different to other people's memories of
that event
and i got looking into the science of it
and
realized that what we're doing when we
are accessing memories we're taking them
out we're
thinking about them experiencing them
when they go back they may be slightly
altered
and so over a period of time
we may have completely different
memories of an event and maybe we have a
family member who has been telling the
same story for 20 years and it's now
very different to the first story they
told
[Music]
we wanted to tell the story about
power and the individual
and
how
these big powers can affect our lives
but the more we worked on this story the
more it became apparent this was a story
about the individual and the individual
choices we make and we realized
the most interesting thing and the most
important thing in our lives are all
those small emotional decisions we make
and the promises we make in life
[Music]
yeah i want to make people
think and feel something
and in south of circle we look at what
are the far-reaching consequences of
your childhood um and this is why i
think video games are a fascinating
media
south of the circle was a very emotional
game to create
it's an emotional game to play
and soon you'll be able to experience
this for yourself
on consoles and pc
stuff of the circle is the future for us
but doesn't mean we forget about our
past for me as one of the creators it's
hard to believe that it's been almost
eight years since the release of this
war of mine and we've been pretty busy
during that time so let me introduce
pablo michovsky we'll tell you more
about it
this war of mine is an extraordinary
game about civilians in war trying to
survive the war released originally in
2014 on pc and final cut is the ultimate
version of the game released only a
month ago on current gen consoles
the game is special on many layers
i mean it speaks about human dignity in
very inhuman times imagine being put in
a war-torn city where you have to deal
with lack of everything food medication
treatment
dealing with constant danger
in such horrible times it takes a lot of
cost and heavy effort to stay human and
this war of mine speaks exactly about it
this war of mine final cut has got a lot
of content comparing to the old gen
version a content inaudible in that one
new civilians new scenarios new
locations so practically the game is a
few times bigger comparing to the old
one
and i need to stress out that
in the game there is no tutorial and you
may ask why
it's simple because in war no one would
tell you how to survive
since 2014
we've been constantly developing the
game adding new story driven scenarios a
lot of free updates
a ton of content including even charity
content that was directed specifically
towards gathering funds for war child in
this case and lately we've organized the
nation for ukrainian red cross just by
selling the game and we amounted 1
million dollars almost
so actually this word of mine is a great
example that
a game can make a change
and be that way something more than just
a game
that's all we've got for you today and i
hope you like it and having an
opportunity to be here i would like to
thank you all for supporting level
episode for so many years because it's
thanks to you that we were able to
achieve so many great things and while
speaking about great things there's
actually one more to come and it's right
around the corner so be sure to follow
up 11 mysterious news in upcoming days
because you're gonna like it trust me
hello i'm jerk tiddle and i'm the writer
and director of the last worker a
first-person narrative adventurer
centered around our struggle in an
increasingly automated world i'm ryan
bowsfield i run wolfenwood and we're
bringing the last worker to pc console
and vr platforms in 2022. the last
worker puts you into the body the mind
and the seat of curt the last human
worker at jungle fulfillment center one
the largest such facility on earth the
size of the sunken city of manhattan
and uh you've been there for 25 years
you've never made a single mistake which
is why you still have your job and
that's why everyone else has lost theirs
it's easy to marvel at the wonders of
jungle but remember
here at jungle time waits for no man you
can say that again it's easy to marvel
at the wonders of young stop but of
course you're not entirely alone in the
game there's skew your only friend and
cobot played by jason isaacs who you
might know from harry potter star trek
discovery death of stalin oliver darry
olefson zelda williams david hewlett
claire hope asherty and tommy earl
jenkins we've got an incredible cast
this area should be off limits
jungle there are no limits so you start
out doing the day-to-day work of curts
dispatching products you're uh keeping
up with the robots but obviously this is
not a work simulator uh you should be
contacted by a group of activists called
spear they want you to kind of delve
deeper into the facility they want you
to take on this espionage we're calling
stealth light gameplay where you do have
to go to these zones where you're not
supposed to be and so you've got to
delve deeper picking up tools and
weapons later on to access these areas
so you're always going to have that push
and pull between the activists and
kurt's pride in his day-to-day job don't
worry she won't hurt you again right
hoverbird i can't promise anything
it's a story and world rich with drama
and even the occasional moments of
horror and a lot of comedy as well
because it's important for us to
build a world that you actually want to
inhabit we wanted to make something that
is crafted with love and full of color
we have been working with mick magmahon
uh the incredible comics legend and
co-creator of judge dredd on designing
these characters in the world with him
and i hope you will enjoy the very
unique look of our game at younger
nothing
the game is packed with so many
surprises and crazy cool moments we just
cannot wait for you to play it later
this year
[Music]
justin remember the frigidaire is red
you can't take your eyes off of it i
mean you don't have to ask me thrice you
know what signals is also looking slick
with its old-school playstation textures
and gritty yet smooth amino style such
awesome like gritty games that's true to
loosen things up you guys don't have to
worry about staring at a crimson ice box
we've got some upbeat style arcade
titles coming at you let's shred right
into it and shred it
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
justin
justin
justin what i'm trying to play witch and
whiz here
what
candy please put down the handheld i
have a really special surprise for you
okay you have my undivided attention now
good
good because next up we're going to go
back to the future and share some neo
retro games soon to be classics that
give you that old school funk that give
you that feeling we're going to start
out with our favorite heroes in a half
shell see what's happening with the
kickstarter symphony of the night indy
south darling and much more this better
be good oh it will be
[Music]
strike
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
teamwork is the way
[Music]
uh
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
teamwork
[Music]
dynamite strikes
[Music]
[Music]
the dragon stirs in the void and an
empire trembles
the rule of the magi lords is failing
where now
shall we place our faith
in the low cunning of the celtics
or in the golden dead
to whom we offer prayers
certainly not in the foul magical praxis
of witches and lay sorcerers
no
this is our punishment
we woke the dragon
and for us
there is no salvation
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
go
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're right candice thank you so much
for crying chopping the handheld because
that was lit turtles in time was my
childhood right there can't wait for the
cowabunga collection shout out to
digital eclipse also bats is out now and
you can pre-order the physical edition
from limited run games i'm gonna pick up
all of those games when they are out of
the oven i am too coming up next are
some surprises that fall into our last
category but also add some new flex to
the rpg and strategy genre as well let's
menu dive into the next set of games
shall we we shall
welcome to wrestle quest the world's
first pro wrestling rpg and the
sweatiest game here at the gorilla
collective showcase i'm zach the head of
narrative here at mega cat studios
andy i'm one of our senior designers
and we've got some content here to show
you that has never been seen before so
wrestle quest includes real world
wrestling legends like macho man randy
savage jeff jarrett jake the snake and
more these guys appeared as giant
statues across the world map with people
coming from all over to pay tribute to
these icons
these sites are also the starting point
for sciquest themed around each legend
here on screen machachu man and his
friends are at the end of one of these
quests they've been investigating a
strange cult of wrestle raiders that
worship the road warriors
after a chase with a mad max style
wasteland the quest comes to a head with
a wrestling match against hawken animal
on the back of a speeding big rig
so each of these side quests around the
real wrestling legends uh some of them
you'll help the wrestlers some of them
you'll end up fighting them like here
and no matter the outcome they're always
the key to the game's best
sometimes you'll get
iconic gear or outfits from the
wrestlers other times you'll be able to
summon them into battle
so i know some rpgs will let you summon
dragons and monsters and whatnot but
only wrestle quest will let you summon
jake the snake to rip a ddt on your
enemies or in this case if you're able
to beat the road warriors you'll be able
to summon them to their doomsday device
andy what's your favorite thing about
the road warriors uh i love the fact
that they can put their mohawks together
to power up
yeah they fit in to each other very
nicely
it's important it's important to have
that type of signature
speaking of uh working together uh
andy's showing you some of our tag team
maneuvers here
muchacho man and toy box you'll be doing
a blockbuster
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a cast of 12 playable characters
in wrestle quest and there's different
combinations of tag team maneuvers and
even triple ticking between them so it's
one more way you can customize how you
play
at the bottom of the screen you'll see
the height meter this is an indication
of the crowd the engagement and interest
in the fight if you come in and you just
spam the attack button they'll get bored
and that'll drain out and your enemies
will get stronger but if you approach
the battle with a little bit more
showmanship and creativity that'll fill
up and you'll start to get bonuses extra
damage
extra loot
better loot ap regeneration it's all
there
[Applause]
there's over 20 wrestling legends to see
in wrestle west
so we'll be excited for you to check
them all out when the game releases
later this year
thanks for checking it out guys
hey folks i'm buddy the community
manager for akupara games and today i'd
like to introduce you to the core
gameplay of zoetty our poker based
roguelike by dusk light games
in zoeti you've got all the ingredients
that make a core roguelike experience
you play as one of a few different
characters with their own unique play
styles as you know you fight your way
through a number of battles before
facing off against the boss and every
time you win a fight you get a reward
you get more powerful before you face
tougher challenges you know like
all of the stuff that makes for a good
roguelike experience
when we get into skills and abilities
that you're using to win those battles
though you know like that's when things
get a little spicy in zoetty you have a
limited number of skill slots and each
one is tied to a particular hand of
poker the rarer the hand the more
powerful the skill two pair is going to
be weaker than you know a straight flush
so in practice this is how it works at
the beginning of the fight you draw a
bunch of cards these are playing cards
and depending on the kinds of poker
hands you can create you can activate
those skills
if you have three of a kind in hand you
can activate the skill tied to three of
a kind so here i'm gonna activate
boundless battle spirit which buffs my
damage a bunch and then i'm gonna
activate it again and then i'm going to
hit a bunch of times with individual
strikes
when you win a battle in zoetty you
don't add more or different cards to
your deck that's always going to stay
the same instead you can add new skills
or level up your existing skills or
acquire different skills for slots that
you already have filled changing out
these skills allows you to really
customize your build and you're always
going to want you know a certain balance
of offense and defense which begs the
question you know do you want a powerful
defensive option something tied to a
straight or a full house or you know do
you want something that's a little bit
weaker but more readily available like a
single pair of cards that you know
you're gonna find that in basically
every hand that you draw
and all of this is affected by the
underlying statistics and modifiers of
the game you know so for instance hand
size or the number of cards you draw per
turn are statistics that you can invest
in you know you keep all of the cards
that you don't play on a turn which
means you can have 11 12 13 cards in
hand which gives you much better access
to some of your deeper more powerful
skills like something tied to a full
house or a straight
you can also increase the amount that
you draw per turn allowing you to just
kind of dump your hand every single turn
for maximum tempo and those are just two
examples there's plenty of cool complex
modifiers that you know you can pick up
to enable really interesting builds for
the game
anyway i think that's about as
complicated as i'm willing to get for
this video for now if you want to learn
more about zoetty i'd recommend
wishlisting us on steam since i'm gonna
be really showing off some of the deeper
more complex mechanics in the not too
distant future and you know that's
probably the best way to keep on top of
things i hope you have a really good
time checking out the awesome titles at
the gorilla collective and you know
otherwise i wish you the best of luck in
your travels cheers
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ah you know kid
the world isn't all sunshine and
rainbows
if you want to be a hero here
just being good isn't enough
because this world is ruled by greed
and greed is exactly what you need here
so kill
[Music]
and blow up
[Music]
and loot
[Music]
[Applause]
anyone who stands in your way
[Music]
on the path to greatness
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone i am nana moon and this
is keylocker turn based cyberpunk action
locker is a turn-based tactical wooden
rpg taking place in a world without
music where you play as the illegal
singer bobo her twin brother and hacker
dealer and the jukebot drummer rocket
you pick up with dealer and rocket
searching for gobo who has been taken by
the satellites the ultimate authorities
of saturn
they have entered the droid factory the
domain of one of saturn's satellites the
lazdu but the way forward is filled with
dangerous force
the combat of key locker takes place on
a tactical route where every move must
be considered plan your actions
carefully as each attack comes with its
own field of damage
timing your attack is crucial for
survival as every perfect hit brings you
closer to victory and every miss closer
to that
some attacks will cause passive effects
to appear on the grids
by using the plug modifier the fabricant
has spawned an electrical feud on one of
the tiles recharging his ep every turn
unfortunately his life points are too
low to take advantage of this strategic
position
[Music]
luckily dealer has spent a long time
preparing for this moment holding keys
to increase his progress on the skill
tree the drives are no match for his
skill level
[Music]
rockets however was only recently given
combat capabilities and could do even
upgrade
let's take a look at his q3 with the
keys we have received from combat
[Music]
the skill tree has two branches
available and each different class gets
an unique one
you start at the top using keys to level
up the talents until it unlocks the next
one below it
talent to increase your stats let you
add unique modifiers to attacks add
passive abilities or unlock new gear for
use
progressing far enough down the skew
tree will even let you cross your skew
tree with another class creating hybrid
classes more on that in the future
if you want to see more of key locker
head over to our steam page and make
sure to wish list and follow
who have a demo available there during
the summer of gaming so make sure to
check that out thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
wow justin wrestle quest looks fantastic
the nostalgia of those pixels brings me
right back to playing royal rumble with
my brother on the genesis i feel you it
also brings me back to some trauma
trauma trauma yeah you know my brother
recorded over all of my high school
cheerleading vhs tapes with episodes of
monday night wrong that is so ridic it
did and it gave me a really bad
relationship with wrestling but there's
something about russell quest that's
making me second guess that and i feel
like i should really let all of this go
you definitely should make that happen
you know what joey
i love you and i forgive you
now i can move on with my life
great breakthrough candace and now that
that's all over we can move on with our
lives and the rest of the show candy how
can we support these devs and their
games by the steam event page justin so
everybody be sure to check out the
gorilla collective 3 event page on steam
definitely support the devs check out
their games wish list them and all that
jazz for sure okay kids it's gc3 key
time here's the qr code take a picture
of it for some of your favorite awesome
gorilla collective games from the
developers and publishers representing
the gc
free keys you love them you see the qr
code take it first come first serve
boom up next on gc3 it is time for some
time for some action we are going to
share some indie titles that represent
tough in the action adventure department
so let's go
hello everyone i'm giacomomasi narrative
director at soulmate games and i'm here
to present to you our latest work patora
lost haven which will launch this fall
patora is a narrative action rpg where
everyone our protagonists will have to
face a cosmic journey and use their
powers to save who and what she loves
making many significant choices that
will change the destiny of the whole
universe
haverill journey will take her to four
different worlds each representing one
of the natural elements the one we are
seeing right now is what the planet of
hair which is composed of five
completely different areas that will
feature a scorching desert this eerie
mountain a mystical river infested by
evil spirits and so much more
we've had a lot of fun creating
intriguing characters with their own
cultures and customs alongside with
colorful and vibrant environments that
you'll get to explore in details thanks
to an in-game zoom
all the planets that everyone will visit
during the game are actually inspired by
real places and human cultures for
example who have is strongly based on
chinese mythologies and settings and
this cute little lizard that we see here
is called uk he's from the xia tribe and
he's also a companion that will help us
in combat while we uncover the secrets
of this mysterious world
speaking of fighting patura features two
different combat styles that revolves
around the main concept of the game
dualism
in her physical form every will be able
to use a sword to fight him melee while
in her mental form she'll be able to
throw projectiles at enemies
switching between them constantly during
fight allows the player to adapt to
every situation and change his strategy
in a split second
this is important because every enemy
inside patura is divided into three
different variations physical mental and
hybrid cell changing out combat style
constantly is essential to emerge
victorious
the nature switch mechanic is also used
to solve many puzzles for example this
one is a memory game that requires the
player to listen to a sequence of notes
and reproduce them with the help of
everyone's physical and mental powers
the narrative side of batura is also
based on duality and players will be
able to shape their own path thanks to
the karma system
during an adventure every will have to
make many difficult decisions and each
of them will have heavy consequences
that may lead to different outcomes and
endings
so are you ready to meet fascinating
creatures explore mysterious planets and
discover where your decisions will take
you
batura lost haven is coming on pcn
consoles this fall don't miss any of the
news and surprises related to batora
which listed right now on stage
as hilda delves deeper into the quest
for her lost father
she will encounter many dangers and
challenges in the city of afes
let us introduce you to one of the main
adversaries that hilda will have to
confront ulelia the prey
famous for her beautiful voice yolelia
used to be the most recognized singer
during aphi's glorious golden age
but like so many others
ulya would fall victim to the curse that
spread across the city a thousand years
ago
the famine brought on by the asterigos
changed her into something else
she turned to an evil cult the etheris
and dedicated herself to it becoming a
symbol by using her reputation and voice
to allow more people to join the cult
[Music]
the encounter starts with ulelia flying
around the top of the seats while
sending attacks like voice shock blasts
feather blades
and cyclones
occasionally she'll descend to the
ground to fight hilda herself with even
more dangerous claw and wing strikes
after some back and forth fights fight
euler would fly to the sky and use her
voice and feather blades to attack hilda
again
and this time she even calls upon
several harpy minions to assist her
during this phase hilda must fight the
minions while watching out for ulya's
deadly attacks from above
once hilda has dealt with the minions
ulya will land again and this time with
despair as she will cause feather storms
to swoop around the amphitheater
this is when the battle culminates the
feather storms will continually fire
sharp blades as hell that cautiously
counters you layla's onslaught in close
combat
in the end only the strongest will
survive
[Music]
we hope you enjoy this preview and we
can't wait to share more about the world
of astarigus with you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
spells and secrets
right
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a tranquil island was hidden from the
world
but one day
its shield vanished
the magical amri once gave life but now
corrupts it
and all creatures great and small are
being enslaved
can you save iknae island
embark on an enchanting adventure
explore a land of secrets
free and befriend all kinds of animals
and use their talents to make new
discoveries
battle enemies
or just hang out
build your home
decorate it however you like
and help develop your hamlet
grow all kinds of crops on your farm
and craft everything you need
to thwart greedy pirates
repel monsters
and uncover mysteries
in time you can explore and restore
peace to ikone island
a new earth lock adventure is about to
begin
igornae island
coming soon on steam
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
[Music]
baby
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey there
don't you love a fun upbeat platformer
in frogen you take control of renata
daughter of world famous archaeologists
and inventors
they didn't allow her to accompany them
to the dangerous ruins of the temple of
beelzebub and now with the help of her
trusty frogen she must save them and
prove that she's a capable explorer too
[Music]
jump zipline grab and throw
the frogen is not only your grappling
hook but also your best friend
with it you can reach over long gaps or
even activate a lever from afar
[Music]
face off against big bug bosses that
serve as the guardians between areas
they may look charming but they're
powerful foes
collect all sorts of treasure including
hats you can swap your helmet with
gallery pictures
tons of metals and a full bestiary
[Music]
be on the lookout for jake he's a young
treasure hunter who'll stop at nothing
to get to the treasure before renata
whenever you find him the race is on
look around for hidden treasure and
alternate paths because every level is
full of surprises and optional
objectives
[Music]
from lush jungles to stinky swamps snowy
mountain tops and lava filled shrines
the varied ruins ensure you'll need to
be prepared for anything
[Music]
but above all else be prepared for lots
of fun in krogan
[Music]
i am loving all of the frog games
hopping around frog gun and the time of
frog island animal oh my god ridiculous
and amazing premises
yeah spells and secrets will definitely
have me showing off my magic touch but
torah so many solid titles okay kids
it's gc3 key time here is the qr code
take a snapshot of it for some awesome
games from developers and publishers
representing the gc gorilla collective
there's a limited time there's a limited
keys we're gonna be popping these up
okay get it that's enough okay
y'all got your keys
boom
up next we're gonna put on our creative
caps and get back into strategy show off
some games that are focused on world
building narrative construction and
tending to your magnificent gardens
let's hop right in and go let's go
tragically
the human civilization has ended
said that the post-apocalypse has got to
be all dire in i am future you find
yourself on the roof in a sunken and
overgrown city once called cosmopolis
where nature rains now
gather food to cook various delicious
dishes
build yourself a base that would work
seamlessly
disassemble the old house appliances to
create new stuff out of old parts
[Music]
explore cosmopolis to find useful
resources and
new friends
i did not expect to see a talking fridge
there
oh well
get away and start your life fresh in i
am future coming to steam in 2022 wish
list now
[Music]
welcome to flat eye a premier fuel
station and technological hub
as the manager of flat eye we're
entrusting you to provide unparalleled
customer service let's explore the
various modules you'll be tasked with to
outfit your station
you'll be able to unlock the new
technologies through the profits you
earn with excellent customer service so
be attentive
at the start your module list will be
limited but each new unit placed opens
up new menus of possibilities
take this toilet module you've installed
thanks to your diligent work stocking
shelves and promptly dealing with
customer purchases you now have enough
to upgrade it to a smart toilet we can
tell so much by analyzing whatever's
going down the drain with this data we
can now safely open a doctor booth to
provide sound medical advice to patrons
so they can have their illnesses
diagnosed and treated with further ilife
branded medical
modules in essence you have the most
important job in the world
flat eye making decisions for the
benefit of everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dinner's ready
be there in just a second mom
there's things in this story
and you are not one of them
you have to help us
save us
from her
[Music]
honey
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look at this justin another dead plant i
could definitely use some gardening tips
show nuff you do not have a green thumb
candy i know i think you know what
justin no more real plants from now on
i'm sticking to animal crossing and
garden in
now for our final segment we're going to
touch your imagination with games that
tickle your soul and jiggle your mind
let's hop into some games that bring a
sense of awe wonder and give you all the
feels jiggle your mind though jiggle
your mind well let's get to jiggling
[Music]
[Music]
it was a hot sunny day
fish died in the lake and birds stopped
singing
those who could escape to mars
i ran deep into the forest where
she-wolf raised me with her cubs
[Music]
many moons later you returned
you hunted and played golf one day i
found one of you dead
so i put his helmet
greetings all you martians out there
it's time for another round of radio
nostalgia from mars
blue skies warm days the long-lost
summers of our past on earth will we
ever return stay tuned for more on that
okay
[Music]
[Music]
a little toddler pop there taking us
back to the days of late stage
capitalism at its finest
child labor never sounded so sweet
[Music]
[Music]
hey [ __ ] cats i'm buddy the community
manager for aquaponic games and today
i'd like to introduce you to the five
new playable slug cats coming in rain
world downpour our new expansion for
rain world coming soon if you haven't
heard about the downpour expansion for
rain world it's bringing a whole host of
new changes characters enemies areas and
more to the rain world experience but
the thing i really want to dig into
today are those five adorable new slug
cats they are the rivulet the
spearmaster the saint the gourmand and
the artificer
up first let's talk about the rivulet
this blue little guy has a ton of
advantages to living in the harsh
foreboding environment of rain world it
runs faster jumps higher and can breathe
underwater which means it can zip across
the map between rainstorms that's the
good news the bad news is one all that
running and swimming burns a ton of
calories two rivals hibernation cycles
are shorter than any other slug cat and
three
it doesn't carry much food over from day
to day play the rivulet if you want to
be agile but don't mind stocking up
between storms if you're looking for a
little more aggression though maybe the
spearmaster will be for you this spiky
slug cat spawns spears which is a tongue
twister that i nailed on the first ride
is my first take definitely not my fifth
one out of its tail which means that
anytime you can start stabbing spiders
scavengers or squid cada the spearmaster
drains one food for every spear it lands
on a target which means it isn't all
that interested in the dangle fruits and
slime mold that other slug cats will
need to sustain themselves if you want
to survive as spearmaster you better be
out for blood play the spearmaster if
you want to be the predator hunting down
prey and aggressively thriving between
brainstorms but maybe you want the
opposite of that aggressive playstyle
well the saint much prefers to avoid
confrontations at all costs which even
includes using its long tongue to
grapple through areas of the world if
the rivulet is nimble in water the saint
is acrobatic in the air and you need to
use that aerial finesse to stay high
above the danger the saint won't even
touch a spear which can leave it a
little bit exposed to being hunted down
and devoured play the saint if you want
to deftly dodge your doom with your
acrobatic antics
okay there's so much more i want to talk
about but i only have like 30 seconds
left there's two more slippery slugs
coming in rain world downpour and i
swear to god one of them is the cutest
thing you have seen in your life
you know the other is just kind of cute
honestly i'm saying that to be nice he's
pretty messed up looking you can go
watch an extended cut of this video
featuring them right now on youtube or
the rain world steam page otherwise i
hope you have a great time at the
gorilla collective cheers
[Music]
um
and
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
he
[Music]
just
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
tandy my soul is genuinely tickled right
now those games were so wonderful so
many amazing games today it was really
incredible over 60 games is crazy thanks
once again to our sponsors and
broadcasting partners for their support
playstation razer astro gaming tencent
our fellow devs and publishers 11-bit
akupara all in games assemble
entertainment aurora punks freedom
graffiti gravity games arise hero craft
modern wolf raw fury tiny build and
wired productions also we cannot forget
our broadcasting partners twitch
gamespot valve and ign for their support
much gratitude you guys a final reminder
to be sure to check out the gorilla
collective event page on steam
definitely check out those games wish
list the games and support them on every
platform huge shout out and thanks to
wilmer sound we are here in berkeley
california in the awesome studio and the
scrappy illustrious mix team as well as
av society be sure to tune in on monday
at 1pm pacific and 4pm eastern where the
gorilla collective gaming greatness will
continue with gc 3.5 also you can follow
the gorilla collective on twitter at
gorilla collect and everywhere else at
gorilla collective as well as the mix at
indiexchange on twitter and at media
indie exchange everywhere else once
again i am your host justin woodward
from the mix with my lovely co-host
candace mckinney thank you again justin
today was so amazing i really appreciate
you having me here i just always had so
much fun with you guys
with that we are signing off and passing
it off to jenny windham aka kimchika to
jump into the warm and full-hearted
world of wholesome games with wholesome
direct we'll see you guys next time
we'll see you soon
peace
hey everyone and thank you so much candy
a huge congratulations to all of the
developers and to the gorilla collective
team for an incredible way to jumpstart
today's festivities my name is jenny
windham i'm with the wholesome games
organizing team and i'm excited to let
you know that the fun does not stop here
we are going to be coming right up next
with this year's wholesome direct
showcase an event highlighting titles
that are uplifting cozy and
compassionate so grab a snack go take a
quick stretch break and make sure you
stick around because we have lots of
games to show you and they're coming
right up
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wholesome direct a
celebration of wholesome games i'm jenny
windham and i'm joined by my wonderful
co-hosts mary kish and josh blaken
sit back and relax as we show you
exclusive footage and announcements from
nearly 100 wholesome games
and don't forget if you see any games
that you love you're gonna want to go to
wholesomegames.com that way you can
learn more about them and you can find
out how to support those devs
alright let's get started
the wasteland is a desolate place
devoid of life
until
the first turbine is constructed
rivers flow once more
and nature's heart
begins to beat
then
it's time to recycle and move on
along the tropical coastline
life thrives anew
parrots flip beneath the verdant canopy
while fish frolic in the abundant coral
reefs
a paradise of biodiversity
even in the most inhospitable of places
life finds a way
we just need to give it a helping hand
this
is terra nil
hello i'm eli and i'm one half of the
development team for a little bear chef
a game about a very small bear in a very
large kitchen who is trying to start his
own successful restaurant you're about
to watch our very first trailer so let's
get cooking
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi i'm majo felix and i'm the composer
and co-director of melody c
hey i'm rich cervantes and i am the
sound designer and co-director of melody
hi i'm host van der andel pastel and
co-director of melody we're happy to
show you a small peak of our game melody
we hope you like it
in melody you follow the story of a
young kid's journey through beautiful
landscapes in search of inspiration
solve block moving puzzles
listen to calm music and discover
relaxing asmr scenes in this stress-free
exploration adventure coming next year
[Music]
jack wants to return nature to its
former glory with the help of his trusty
axe and his animal friends
[Music]
slice through machinery slap some scents
into wasteful humans and work with
flacky woodland critters to thwart the
sinister clans of industrial giant evil
works
[Music]
[Music]
hi i'm louis durant developer of the
garden path maybe you recognize the game
from last year's wholesome direct the
garden path is a slice of life sim about
the joy of gardening designed to be
played in short moments time in the game
runs in concert to the real world and
the passing seasons bring with them new
stories errands as well as a living
garden that grows as you tend it the
garden path is releasing just later this
year on pc mac linux and nintendo switch
and if you're looking to explore the
garden early we're running unlimited
access to the game on hio thanks and
enjoy the rest of the direct
[Music]
this is mika and the witches mountain a
relaxing experience where you're an
aspiring witch
help the townspeople by carrying their
packages and discover hidden secrets
while soaring freely on your magic broom
you'll be enchanted by stories from the
locals and the colorful art style
time here has a way of flying by
[Music]
hey there i'm lauren i'm colleen and
this is max we are making taxi box with
a team of friends
there's a new demo on steam if you want
to give it a try and now enjoy the
trailer enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's mail time as a newly trained male
scout put on your pack grab those
letters and deliver them across grumble
wood grove
since its appearance in last year's
wholesome snag
mail time has had a successful
kickstarter confirmed a switch
switchport
and is debuting a new area here for the
first time
[Music]
in this very first gameplay trailer for
usagi shima we get a taste of the cozy
relaxing bunny collecting game
decorate and abandon island and discover
and make friends with a variety of cute
curious bunnies
[Music]
we're just getting started but i'd like
to take a moment to mention our
collaboration with the galaxy fund
helping bring games from nothing to
something this is a prototype grant
focused on the early stages of
development for bipoc and queer creators
each creator is free to use the funds
however they want like staffing hardware
coaching legal fees child care or
therapy
we've partnered with the yeti to offer
two limited time wholesome direct
t-shirts celebrating today's event and
100 of the proceeds will go to the
galaxy fund this is one small but
impactful step that we can take to make
our industry a more inclusive space
where bold new ideas can flourish if
you'd like to learn more head over to
supportgalaxy.fun
and get your limited time shirts over at
the yeti.com
wholesome games
hello
i'm back again
i can't believe it's been a year since
we announced a walk with yaya last
year's wholesome direct i've added lots
of new things to the game in the last
year and we have a brand new trailer for
the game check it out
check it out
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
play as an adorable chicken on an
adventure to find the answer to the
question which came first the chicken or
the egg
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
free ride is an rpg that's secretly a
personality test
you'll never be judged in terms of good
or evil and you'll never know when
you're making decisions
[Music]
ready to find out who you are
[Music]
hello everyone i'm baptist one of the
co-authors of how to say goodbye and
this is bruna
she's one of the many ghosts who will
help move forward in the afterlife
our upcoming narrative puzzle game talks
about grief and how to deal with it in a
kind and sensitive way we hope you'll
enjoy it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you may remember this game from the
first ever wholesome direct back in 2020
calico is a silly and sweet day in the
life community sam the new possum update
adds a new and improved cooking game
with all sorts of mini games for the
different recipes
there's also wallpaper and rug
customization and new farm animals to
collect
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
once upon a time there was a small
animal village where everyone lived in
peace and harmony
until the king suddenly disappeared
now it's up to you to help peep and his
friends find sir barrington
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
explore an ever-changing board
game-sized world where each playthrough
is different
use your ability strategically to
outplay and defeat bows
[Applause]
meet cute characters and relax with your
friends at the campfires
[Music]
paper animal rpg now on kickstarter and
get notified when the campaign launches
in summer 2022
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fall of porcupine is a unique story
adventure about an unhealthy healthcare
system
not only is there a lot to discover in
the old hospital but also in the small
town itself
the last clock winder is a vr puzzle
game set in a cozy sci-fi world
your mission is to repair the clock
tower an ancient haven for the world's
plants and seeds built into the trunk of
a colossal tree
use a pair of magical gloves to turn
every simple task into a looping
clockwork automaton
these clones can do everything you can
do from planting to storing to passing
items around
hi this is anonymous penguin studio and
this is our game lovebird you can follow
us on adamtangu studio on twitter for
more updates on our release but until
then goodbye and stay wholesome
[Music]
in lovebird you play as a heartbroken
bird ready to dip back into the dating
scene
impress your dates by flirting to the
rhythm of the music
sometimes you'll succeed
sometimes you won't
[Music]
sometimes it gets a little awkward
your goal is to find your one true love
so keep swiping
[Music]
welcome to the world of spirit swap
lo-fi beats to match 3-2 a joyful queer
game about friends thirst and figuring
out why so many spirits keep popping up
in your town it's an action puzzle game
with a focus on lovable characters
despite appearances the game can get
pretty intense but don't worry you'll
always be able to make it fit your mood
play the new limited time demo now on
steam featuring updated art music and
story moments and get ready to enjoy the
full game in 2023 thanks for watching
[Music]
coffee talk episode 2 the viscous and
butterfly is the sequel to the hit
coffee brewing game coffee talk
[Music]
episode 2 will have new characters new
features and new drinks to serve to your
favorite patrons
[Music]
get your apron on and sharpen your
barista skills for 2023
[Music]
hello and welcome to the musical world
of odara let me introduce you to our
protagonists
blue house
red house
and a yellow house
you can place them wherever you like
or even on top of each other
for every decision you make you'll get a
different rhythm or a different melody
and you'll be able to create your own
songs with it but enough words let's
listen to some music
[Music]
[Music]
in froggon your grappling gun is a frog
and that frog is your best friend
[Music]
help renata save her parents in the
mysterious ruins
[Music]
my
build a garden grow plants for your
potions and spells and forage
friendships with the townsfolk and
garden witch life
[Music]
next time on a new episode of princess
farmer with the mystery solved everyone
is off to the island for a well-deserved
vacation
now's the time to kick up their feet
relax and oh what's that there's a shell
matching tournament
[Music]
the first episode in a three-part story
the guardians beach break part 1
launches for free this summer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for those just joining we'd like to
remind you about our collaboration with
the galaxy fund
equity begins at the leadership level
and sometimes those initial barriers are
the hardest to overcome
that's where the galaxy fund comes in
it's a prototype grant focused on the
early stages of development from bipod
and queer creators
we've partnered with the yeti to offer
two limited time wholesome direct
t-shirts celebrating today's event and
100 of the proceeds will go to
supporting the galaxy fund
this is one small but important step
that we can take towards making our
industry a more inclusive space where
bold new ideas can flourish
if you'd like to learn more you can
visit
supportgalaxy.fund and get your limited
time t-shirts at the yeti.com
wholesome games
hi we are smarter club
last year we released teacup a wholesome
adventure game about a t loving frog
william for airs in the forest this year
we're happy to share with you a teaser
trailer for our new game bubblegum
galaxy
a chill building strategy game about
rebuilding the universe time by time
please enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
hello everyone
here comes niko will be getting free dlc
as part of the next update
it'll be coming to both pc and nintendo
switch
we hope you look forward to exploring
gary's garden soon bye bye
[Music]
snufkin melody of moomin valley is a
musical adventure game about restoring
harmony and balance to moomin valley
protecting it from the industrious park
keeper moomin was created by tove
johnson in the 1940s and started out as
a series of books and comics
the stories are about an adventurous
family of movement roles living in a
lovely house with many interesting
friends tulvionson was not only a great
writer but also an amazing illustrator
and artist we want the game to look and
feel like something tova herself could
have envisioned
snufkin is our favorite character he's a
vagabond who's deeply connected with
nature he enjoys his own company but is
also very fond of his best friend
moomintroll
it's a cozy adventure with story music
and melancholic atmosphere as some of
its most important ingredients and a
tiny bit of mischief
the game is set to release on pc and
console in 2023 and you can wish list it
on steam right now
feed all monsters is a cute and cozy
line puzzle game
assist a team of delivery workers in
their quest to bring tasty food to all
the little monsters
[Applause]
find the optimal path for each worker in
order to get all the monsters fed
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
paper trail is a top-down puzzle
adventure about leaving home set in a
paper world
[Music]
you must fold and tear your way through
a diverse populated paper world
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
solitaire is a relaxed rogue-like story
game in which you can catch a glimpse of
the future via solitaire
[Music]
the twist lies in interpreting the
card's meaning and which future they
foretell
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
the games and online harassment hotline
is a text message based anonymous and
confidential emotional support hotline
and it's created specifically for the
gaming community because we're gamers
and creators and we want to help each
other
so
how does it work
well you text us and we listen our
hotline is 100 anonymous we can talk
about anything you need to and only what
you want to
the games and online harassment hotline
is an inclusive resource for anyone no
matter how you identify if you feel that
you need emotional support you can start
right now by texting support to 23368
and our qualified responders will be
there to listen to you free of charge
reach out get help and let's make this
community a better place to work and
play
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a frog's tail is an rpg with a unique
battle system puzzles and platforming
challenges synced to the beat of the
music
[Music]
[Music]
explore vivid locations meet a cast of
unforgettable animal characters
and uncover the secrets of the frog
goddess anura in this emotional journey
in freshly frosted use health puzzles in
the world's most adorable donut factory
[Music]
place conveyor belts to guide these
delicious donuts to their destinations
[Music]
enjoy a dozen donut boxes each with
unique flavor mechanics and adorable
donuts
[Music]
out today on nintendo's switch xbox
playstation steam and epic game store
colossal kaiju have appeared around the
world to bring an end to humanity
these kaiju aren't killers lucky they're
just looking for love
[Music]
[Music]
connect with nature in this adorable
cottage core life sim about foraging
cooking and crafting
live in harmony with nature while
learning real-life plant and mushroom
identification
[Music]
cook dishes and make herbal remedies
that you can sell at the local farmers
market
[Music]
customize your character and decorate
your home while making cute decorations
and upcycling furniture
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
in the grassland highlights the rural
life of the gaucho pampas and their
mysticisms
return to the land of your childhood
rebuild your family's ranch with your
friends cusco and alazon and experience
adventures in this fantastic universe of
gaucho culture
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
bye
my
[Music]
hi wholesome i'm luca lead singer of ofk
this is debug
they are a cat hologram and on monday
june 13th we are releasing a free demo
of our music biopic game at steam
nexfest
we hope that our little story can be
something that you relate to
this is just us sharing our experience
that it is so hard to just make
something
and to share it with people
so many things get in the way like jobs
or heartbreak or losing a friend
so i guess
we are ofk is a story about the things
that get in the way
good and bad
see you monday at steam next fest
moonberry's residents need healing and
you're the best chemist around
[Music]
with your trusty tools a brewing
cauldron and a canine companion at your
side you'll need to diagnose symptoms
gather ingredients brew potions and cure
ailments in this open-ended sim rpg
[Music]
[Music]
jump from shadow to shadow in this
colorful beautifully animated world
[Laughter]
help other characters along your journey
as you seek to reunite with your human
counterpart
[Music]
[Music]
friends
[Music]
in bilkin's folly plays take on the role
of treasure hunter percy bilkins and his
best friend drayton as they track down
percy's mother and grandfather lost
somewhere among a group of fictitious
caribbean islands in the late 1700s
over the course of their journey adora
will acquire a ship and visit exotic
locations discover a terrible family
secret and attempt to break the curse of
bilkin's folly before it's too late
for all this percy will build on a
relationship with his own dog and crew
and discover the true meaning of family
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
fill the world with blocks
and don't forget to clean up the mess
[Music]
explore colorful and vibrant worlds in
this 3d platformer adventure around the
cosmos
one last time we'd like to talk about
our collaboration with the galaxy fund
the galaxy fund is a prototype grant
focused on the earliest stages of game
development from bypoc and queer
creators
we've partnered with the yeti to offer
two limited time wholesome direct
t-shirts celebrating today's event and
100 of the proceeds go to supporting the
galaxy fund this is one small but
impactful step that we can take towards
making our industry a more inclusive
place where bold new ideas can flourish
if you'd like to learn more you can
visit
supportgalaxy.fund and get your limited
time shirts at the yeti.com
wholesome games
[Music]
welcome aboard tracks of thought
next stop the dining car
[Music]
here you can buy yummy snacks that will
help you on your journey
[Music]
your choices will shape the game giving
you personal challenges to overcome
[Music]
embrace yourself
play the demo on steam right now
[Music]
hi i'm i and i'm on a quest through
school to find the boy i love but
whenever i think about him it feels like
time slows down all around me i'll have
to toy with time solve puzzles
[Music]
you've been invited here to restore the
island alongside adorable creatures
known as critter crops in this 100
hand-drawn halloween themed farming sim
you'll play as sylvie a young witch who
is run out of her home due to her
newfound abilities invite outcasts to
stay in your town and protect your way
of life unlock magical spells to protect
yourself and your critters and restore
the island to its former glory
[Music]
hey everyone my name is lucy and i'm one
of the two devs behind the spirit and
the mouse today we wanted to share new
gameplay details with you your main
mission will be to find listen to and
help villagers in trouble around town
while exploring you will also find
collectibles hidden about
i heard when kiblin is willing to trade
them for upgrades
to celebrate wholesome direct we
prepared the demo for you and it's
available right now we hope you will
enjoy it
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
there's a lot to tidy up in a little to
the left
every day brings something new with the
daily tidy delivery
the daily tidy takes puzzles from the
game and gives them a special twist
with many variations of these puzzles
you'll get something different every day
unique to you
and you can earn fun badges too
[Music]
not that you don't already have your
paws full
hey there we're aesthetician labs as you
may have heard we were brought onto
cacopa's atlas to continue development
earlier this year in kokopa's atlas you
will embark on a grand journey to an
unknown planet since last year we've
been working hard to implement a
procedurally generated farm and crafting
adventure following our adorable
adventurers cocopa and palmeiro we're
really excited about our vision for the
game and we hope that our new wholesome
direct exclusive demo will get you
excited too we'd love for you to check
it out and let us know what you think
the wandering village is a city building
simulation game on the back of a giant
creature called
it's a game about symbiosis in which you
traverse a toxic world together
so take good care of onbu
make sure to keep it happy and healthy
by feeding it and sending out your pets
regularly
and since andui is a good boy don't
forget the pets
and you will be rewarded with its trust
[Music]
lonesome village combines puzzle solving
and social sim elements to create
something completely unique
everything is wrapped in a fantasy
adventure with a deep intriguing story
and no combat
plays wes the coyote to help unravel the
calamity that befell the village
coming this year to steam nintendo
switch xbox one and xbox series x
it's almost time to say goodbye
but before we go we'd like to share even
more wholesome games with you coming out
this year and beyond
now these are gonna go pretty fast so
after the show you can visit
wholesomegames.com for more information
and links to all of these games
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
my
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and that brings us to the end of today's
program remember to visit
wholesomegames.com to find links to
every title featured in today's show it
would mean so much to us if you'd follow
and wish list all of these amazing games
and we'll see you again next year for
wholesome direct 2023 but before we go
here's one more game we hope you'll love
bye
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you